buenos días
qué tal habéis dormido
sobre colchonetas y camas plegables
amanecen un día más los médicos atención
primaria de la sanidad pública de Madrid
tras meses en huelga para exigir mejores
condiciones médicos y pediatras han
decidido hacer algo distinto y organizar
un encierro ensamblando fuerzas uniendo
energías y sobre todo revitalizando una
huelga que lleva ya camino de ocho
semanas muy largo pero yo creo que al
final tanta Unión y tanta fuerza se
tiene que notar
es que me encanta el chocolate como si
de una familia más se tratara desayunan
juntos y conversan sobre sus
preocupaciones
pedimos 10 minutos por paciente los
médicos de familia y 15 minutos por
paciente en pediatría en estos momentos
tienen a un paciente cada cinco minutos
Así que para aumentar el tiempo de
atención haría falta un 20% más de
médicos
este encierro indefinido empezó con unos
15 integrantes Ahora son más de 100
médicos que se van rotando
Hola buenas tardes
aquí os traemos un poquito de tal de
parte de parte de ahí del bar Óscar los
pacientes nos quieren en pacientes lo
cuidan los pacientes nos mantienen vivos
a medida que avanza la tarde los ánimos
suben para el momento álgido de la
jornada las 8 de la noche cuando suenan
de nuevos esos aplausos que se asomaban
cada día a las ventanas y Balcones de
toda España durante la pandemia pero
solamente por vuestro aplauso de ahora
por el cariño que nos dais por el amor
que nos estáis dando estáis consiguiendo
que cada día estemos más fuertes que
aquí hacemos más animados
una fortaleza y un ánimo esenciales en
quienes con sus cuidados y prevención y
sobre todo con tiempo son capaces de
reducir en un 25% la mortalidad de sus
pacientes